In October 2017, a
SWAT team showed up at Jameson
Lopp’s house in North Carolina,
allegedly
because of a fake complaint
by a person
angered by one of his tweets.
So he posted a video of himself
firing an AR-15
and then embarked on a journey
to disappear in the physical world,
unreachable by his enemies,
and far from the prying eyes
of the surveillance state.
Lopp had been obsessed with privacy
long before the SWAT-ing.
He's visually a
throwback to the long bearded
mathematicians and cipher punks
who in the nineties
believed that recent breakthroughs
in cryptography
could enable levels
of personal freedom and privacy
beyond anyone's wildest dreams.
Many of the ideas
and technical innovations
that came out of the Cypherpunk
movement were eventually folded
into Bitcoin.
Government
is not a monolithic thing,
which is your enemy.
It's a multitudinous thing
Lopp even calls himself
a professional cypherpunk.
Carrying on the movement's legacy,
the company Lopp co-founded, Casa,
is trying to make it easier
for people to hold custody
of their own Bitcoin.
In keeping with the Cypherpunk
ethos,
instead of storing their money
on third party exchanges
where regulators can impose
arbitrary rules.
After the SWAT raid, Lopp
changed his phone number, set up
LLCs to hide his true
name and address,
encrypted his communications
and even bought a decoy house
to serve
as a physical mailing address,
which he needed
to satisfy the DMV's requirement
for a driver's license.
To check his work,
he hired private investigators
to tail him.
We the cipher punks are dedicated
to building
anonymous systems,
wrote Eric Hughes
in his 1993 manifesto,
and we don't much care
if you don't approve
of the software we write.
Jameson Lopp is an enigmatic
privacy obsessive,
fighting to keep that dream alive.
Why should I
self-custody my Bitcoin?
Well,
it really comes down to what
security model you want
and why Bitcoin was created
in the first place.
I mean, you read the whitepaper,
you read what Satoshi said.
Trusted third
parties are security holes.
This is,
this is a fundamental issue
that we've been dealing with,
you know, from inception.
When we talk about
being your own bank.
It's, it's
something that Satoshi
sought to make possible, but
from a feasible perspective,
most people don't
want to be their own bank.
There's there's a reason
why banks exist.
People don't want to
have to deal with
all of the hassles that come
with securing
highly valuable things.
But what we're really saying
is, like,
if you want to have a level of bank
security,
if you want to be able to operate
in such a way
that you don't have
to ask permission
from a third party,
then you do have to take
on some responsibility.
And, you know,
this is a problem
that I've been working on
for eight years now,
and we're still a long ways away
from having it solved.
But I do believe, you know,
we keep making incremental progress
towards decreasing
the amount of effort
that is required
for someone to be their own bank.
What does that look like,
decreasing the amount
of effort required?
It involves
taking all of these best practices
and all of these things
that we have learned over
the years,
really learning from other people's
mistakes and catastrophes
and packing,
packaging that up into user
friendly software
so that the user doesn't
have to read
novels and novels of documents
about what the best practices are.
Rather,
they just follow the instructions
of what the software
is telling them to do,
and that puts them into a position
where they are
automatically following
the best practices.
Well, so what does that look like
a little bit more concretely?
Like, say,
I personally am
trying to start on the journey
specifically
or what are two or three steps
I could take to begin
to take control of my own privacy
to a greater extent and stop using,
you know, Coinbase.
Yeah.
So I look at it in terms of
what do you have to lose
and how much value are you storing
in Bitcoin?
If somebody is only doing
pocket money,
maybe $100 a few hundred dollars,
just download
one of the free apps out there
and then you have
your private keys on your phone.
You know, that is a hot wallet.
It is.
It is one of
the least secure ways of doing it.
But it is
in many ways
still better than having your keys
with a third party.
If you're going up a level,
if you have, you know,
thousands of dollars,
a non-trivial amount,
that's when you probably want to
invest $50
to $100
in a dedicated hardware device.
There's a number of them
out there on the market.
None of them are perfect.
They all have pros and cons,
strengths and weaknesses.
But really,
any of them is better than
none of them.
Better than having,
you know, your keys
either with a trusted third party
or just on an
Internet connected device,
which is easier for hackers
to get into.
My living room
is going to be littered
with air gapped devices soon.
Perfect.
Yeah, And
especially if you want to
become a power user
or just try a number of them out.
Like I said,
they all offer
different security models,
different user experiences.
You know,
I have drawers and drawers
full of different ones
and I have plenty
of opinions around
which ones I like and dislike
or would recommend to people.
But then really the next tier is-
the best way I can describe
it is
you're trying to eliminate
every possible
single point of failure.
The problem with these bearer
assets,
the problem with empowering people
with cryptography,
is that we're essentially handing
toxic waste to them
or radioactive material,
if you will.
It's a private key that unlocks
the functionality
to these assets,
these different networks.
And, you know,
as long as you can keep
that tiny amount of data safe
so that nobody other than yourself
has access to it,
you're sovereign, you know,
you're immensely powerful
within that network.
You're able
to use the functionality
of that network.
But as soon as somebody
gets access
to that little bit of data,
they can basically
step into your shoes
and generally what happens is
catastrophic loss.
You know,
one second and you have everything.
The next second, it's all gone
and there is no authority
that can get it back for you.
So it's,
you know,
to eliminate
single points of failure,
we have to implement
best practices.
We have to leverage
functionality of these protocols
to basically
use multiple different keys
instead of just having one key.
And so
this is generally
called multi-signature.
You know, it's functionality
that a lot of these
protocols offer.
And that just means that
you create keys
and you store them
in different places
on different types of hardware.
And you can
you can create resiliency
and redundancy.
And this is really
what I've been doing
for almost eight years now
in a couple of different companies,
couple of different capacities.
It's trying to make it easier
for non-technical and normal people
to put themselves
into that position
and basically create
what I consider
to be a better than bank
level of security.
Because if you think about it,
even the most secure bank vault,
even, you know,
a fortress that is, you know,
guarded by military,
that is like
a single physical location,
which is in itself
still a single point of failure,
but with cryptography,
with private keys.
Now we can actually decentralize
your security
and make it so
that, you know, an attacker
would actually have to compromise
many different points.
And this just creates
a level of security
that's never been possible before.
So you were profiled,
somewhat surprisingly,
by The New York Times,
specifically about your attempts
to evade the surveillance state.
What steps
did you take to disappear yourself?
It was nearly a year
long process of investigating
exactly all the different ways
that our data is leaked.
Now, I had a fair amount of
of background of understanding
how your data, how you get tracked
and how your data gets leaked,
just as you're doing
normal Internet
browsing activity
is because
I spent ten years
working at an email
marketing company.
I was the guy
collecting all of your data
and running analytics on it.
And as a result,
I'm quite aware of just, you know,
how many trackers there are
whenever you're doing
anything on the Internet.
So, you know, there was,
there was that level of technical
sophistication of just
trying to block stuff,
ad blockers, VPNs,
so on and so forth.
But that's actually the easy part.
The hard part is more on the legal
side, the government side.
The most difficult
being, of course,
your driver's license,
things that are
tied to your ownership of,
you know, quote
unquote, real assets. Like a house.
Like a house, like a car,
you know,
anything that you have to register
with the state.
That's where it gets really tricky
and it becomes
jurisdiction specific.
But, you know,
there are states where it is
possible to create trusts.
It's possible
to create corporations
that you can use
as proxies or shields
to essentially hide
the true name, the true ownership.
Unfortunately, this is not simple.
It's not cheap.
It requires
time and money and lawyers.
But if you do it
and you’re
extremely diligent about it,
you can,
you know, button up
all of the holes,
as it were, and prevent
any of the the data from leaking.
But it requires an ongoing effort.
Did you make an LLC?
Oh, yes, I have.
You know,
a number of different trusts.
An LLC
is an- LLCs owned by other LLCs
that are owned by trusts.
You know,
it really is the shell game.
So you have layers
to this essentially.
Absolutely.
Do you have a sense
of how much it costs
to do that type of thing?
Because presumably
that's a barrier
that disallows some people
from actually evading surveillance
the way they want to.
Generally,
at least a few thousand dollars.
Okay.
But outside of
just the legal costs,
I would say the higher ongoing
maintenance costs
is with my driver's license and my,
you know, quote unquote, residence.
The address
that, you know, the state
considers to be my residence.
And unfortunately,
the only way
that I've really been able
to find a solution to
that is literally find the cheapest
apartment, house, hovel or what
have you that has, you know,
a physical mailbox.
There are ways that you can get
really creative.
The shortest version of
I guess a way to describe it is
you look into
RV life
forums or digital nomad forums.
There are some states out there,
I think Nebraska, perhaps,
where you can very easily,
in a matter of a few weeks,
get a driver's license
and establish quote
unquote residency.
But it just depends on
how much effort
you're willing to put into it.
Both self-custody
and disappearing yourself
require, like
from the panopticon, essentially,
require a pretty high
level of technical skill,
obviously disappearing yourself
from the state
the way that you did requires
so much more skill than
you know, self-custody.
Is there any way that this can
actually catch on en masse?
Yeah, I am definitely bearish
on this
being adopted
even by more than a small
contingent of people.
I would say
it's really relegated
more to like the celebrities
and the ultra wealthy,
you know, the people who
for one reason or other,
they may have stalkers,
they may suspect that
they will have stalkers
or they're just high profile enough
and have enough wealth
that, you know,
spending thousands of dollars
doesn't really mean much to them.
You know, it is
it is a form of insurance policy.
And, you know,
when it comes to both privacy
and security,
unfortunately, my experience over
the past decade has been that
basically nobody values
their privacy and security
until it's too late. Self-custody.
Is that something that is likely
to catch on
with the general public,
or do you think the barrier might
still be too high?
There is a high barrier.
Like I said,
I've been trying to bring it down
for eight years and it's-
there's no end in sight to that.
But really part of the problem is
the level of advantage
that custodians and trusted
third parties have
when it comes to convenience
and user experience.
It's because they control
the entire experience.
Do you think there's ever
a future where we can get
grandmas to self-custody?
Well, it's definitely possible.
And, you know,
I can tell you from experience,
we have plenty of people
in their eighties
who are clients of Casa.
We have
you know,
we have combined
both the user experience
and a level of service.
So it's possible,
but there's
just the question of incentives.
And so,
you know, part of the problem
also is just
what is the onboarding process
look like?
If someone wants to
get into Bitcoin right
now, probably
99% of people
get onboarded
by signing up at an exchange.
Yeah.
They are, you know,
start off
using a trusted third party
and usually that's also
where they stop.
They either don't look into
or they don't
understand that, you know,
withdrawing to
self-custody is an option.
Or if they do see it as an option,
it's just too scary.
They don't want to deal with it.
So I am, I would say, more bullish
on a future
in which we have more on ramps,
by which
I mean
people are engaging in commerce
and they're just directly
receiving Bitcoin
and probably over
Lightning Network.
And, you know,
that's
something that we're starting
to see happen,
especially as we're seeing,
for example, Nostr,
a new protocol, a new network
that has come online
that is, is
really more of a Lightning
native experience.
And with that being integrated
into a lot of the clients,
people are very easily
just setting up, you know,
self-custody wallets
and directly receiving money
without ever signing up
on a custodian or an exchange.
So Nostr’s
sort of the gateway drug.
Yeah, it's
one of many possible futures,
and I think there's
many different ways that we can,
you know,
create new experiences
where people are getting onboarded
directly
into a self-custody environment.
But I think we will have a diverse
ecosystem and range of custody,
and it doesn't actually
necessarily need to be a
binary thing.
It doesn't have to be just trusted
third party or just self-custody.
And this is actually where
some of the recent innovations in
Bitcoin scripting
and programing language
are becoming very interesting
to me
as a builder of
self-custody products.
But suffice to say
some of the other ways
that you could
try to find
a happy medium
between these two extremes
are things like
hybrid custody,
where you have
multiple keys that are shared
perhaps between you, family,
other semi trusted experts.
I think that, you know,
there is a push happening
towards community banking models.
This is something
that we're seeing,
for example,
with the Fedimint project,
you know, Fedi is building software
that's making it easier for,
you know,
your local family
or your local community bank
to be providing
what you know,
that would still be a third party
custody model, but that would
hopefully create a world in which
instead of having ten
or 100 custodians
holding the majority of Bitcoin
for everyone,
we would have thousands,
if not tens
or hundreds of thousands of smaller
regional custodians
that are helping people
manage that money.
So the point being, you know,
it still gives
some risk to the end users.
But from a really high level,
you don't have the same level
of systemic risk.
And that's
what really worries me
is if too much of the Bitcoin
goes into too few hands,
especially if they're like
regulated companies
that can be easily
targeted by nation states,
that is when Bitcoin itself,
you know, as a network becomes
a bit more prone to, you know,
nation state actions.
Do you self-custody
all of your crypto?
Not all.
You know,
I have a
diverse range of different set ups.
What does that breakdown look like?
Like how do you make that decision
about how much to self-custody?
Well, you know,
some of it is actually legal.
For example, you know, retirement
funds,
it can be much more difficult to
to have, you know, self-custody
Bitcoin
as a part of a retirement fund.
It's certainly far more
easy to
use, you know,
one of the products
that's out there on the market.
What kinds of changes
to Bitcoin's
protocol are needed
in the coming years?
It was very controversial topic
to say that Bitcoin needs
anything at all.
Yeah, but, you know.
Do you reject the premise?
So I would say, you
know, Bitcoin
doesn't need anything to survive.
Mm hmm.
But as a technologist,
I believe that in order
for Bitcoin to thrive
and to become a
more developer
friendly, more secure, or at least
secure in terms
of like end user security
security models
for self-custody, more scalable,
then we do want to see some changes
that will make it possible
for more permissionless innovation.
Basically,
you know,
we don't want people
to have to screw around
with the Bitcoin protocol
and make a lot of changes to it,
that's very contentious.
We went through multiyear debates
around making some changes
to Bitcoin a few years ago.
But what we're lacking
is the ability for people
to go out
and easily create
other layers of technologies
that are cryptographically
linked to Bitcoin
where they can basically use
those as playgrounds
for experimentation
and be able to do
whatever they want
without having to ask permission
to change Bitcoin,
without having to worry
about accidentally
doing something that breaks
Bitcoin itself.
Well, so explain
a little bit of the controversy
surrounding this.
Without making
any new enemies, ideally?
Yeah.
Well, you know,
one example is that,
you know,
whenever you change software,
especially when you're changing
something like Bitcoin,
which is it
is programable money, you know,
it does have a programing language,
even though it's very basic
in what it can do.
You know,
whenever you're creating
new functionality
that is going to be leveraged
by developers,
it's always possible
that that functionality
could be used in unintended ways.
And so we've had a little
bit of controversy
just over the past month or two
with some people
leveraging functionality
that got activated a few years ago
to do new things
that had not been anticipated.
And you could argue that
it was not the
intended purpose of the function.
Like what?
So basically,
you know,
people have discovered
new ways of storing data
in the Bitcoin blockchain
that it wasn't as easy to do
before.
It was possible,
but it just wasn't as easy.
And, you know,
some people get upset
when Bitcoin is used for,
you know, non-monetary
transactions and purposes
and data storage.
But I'm a technologist,
so I've always looked at Bitcoin
as a type of database.
It's just the
the least efficient
type of database
that I've ever seen.
So the most difficult database
to try to work with.
But as a database, as a
a store of historical records,
it provides
some very interesting guarantees
that no database
has ever been able to do before.
I assume you're
talking a little bit
about ordinals, the ability
to put JPEGs on the blockchain
or what have you.
What do you think of that? Right.
I mean, I'm quite neutral.
I'm ambivalent on it.
I'm personally not
interested in NFTs or
trading other tokens that
people are creating
using the Bitcoin blockchain
to do that.
But I'm a free market proponent,
so I'm not against people
developing new functionality
and new ways
of having economic interactions
using Bitcoin
and related technology.
This is, this is controversial
because I think there's
generally two perspectives
that are being taken
with regard to how bitcoin
quote unquote should be used.
It's, you know,
how do you try to describe
or define,
quote unquote spam,
you know, spammy
use of the blockchain?
Because the Bitcoin blockchain
is a scarce shared resource.
And you can certainly run
into a sort of tragedy
of the commons situation
whenever you have a scarce
shared resource.
So on one hand,
you have people
who essentially are
placing subjective arguments around
what they believe
should be a Bitcoin transaction,
you know,
and generally
that comes down to, well, a Bitcoin
transaction should just be sending,
you know,
Satoshis value
from one person to another
and that's it.
It's not about, you know,
putting a bunch of data
into the blockchain
and then calling it something else
and then saying it's
a token transfer.
They, their,
you know, subjective perspective
says that
that is not the original
intended design
and use of Bitcoin,
but as it is with any subjective
arguments, people will take
the opposite side
of that and say, Hey,
you should be able to
do whatever you want
as long as the protocol says
it's valid.
So I consider the opposite
side of that usually
to be more of an objective
economic argument,
which is the only,
the only definition of spam
when it comes to
Bitcoin transactions
and use of the network
that I can figure is,
are you paying a competitive fee
to get into the blockchain?
You know,
what are you willing to pay?
Because
if you're willing to pay
more than someone else,
then that probably means
that what you're doing,
you know, is more valuable to you
than what someone else is doing.
If they're not willing
to pay as much.
And that's
seems to be the most reasonable way
to decide, you know,
what data goes into the blockchain,
because we cannot
put the entire world's
data into the blockchain.
I'm really curious,
does Bitcoin
have a developer shortage,
especially compared
to like Ethereum?
There is definitely
far fewer developers
and I think a big part of that
is because of how much more limited
the functionality
is, of how much less
developer friendly.
A lot of the tooling is.
But that is changing.
We are seeing,
you know, for example,
there's something called
mini script
that has been developed
over the past few years
and I'm seeing more
and more tooling
that is coming up around
making it easier
for developers
to create more complex
locking scripts
with many different,
you know,
logical branches and conditions
and basically
allowing us
to create much more interesting
self-custody security models.
Okay,
so say I were super concerned
about hyperinflation,
not to the point
where I would make any sort of
like thing like that,
but how should someone
prepare for hyper inflation?
Well,
you know, as Satoshi said, it, uh,
it might make sense
to get a little bit
just in case this catches on.
So, you know, holding
I've always looked at Bitcoin
from inception
of when I got into it.
I've looked at it
as a sort of hedge,
a very long term
hedge, just
Bitcoin
does not have any guarantees
or even have any goals
with regard to its price
and its exchange rate.
It has no concept of its own
exchange rate.
However, while we can't be sure of
what's going to happen
with Bitcoin's exchange rate,
it's very volatile.
Over a short, medium
term time
periods, could go up or down,
whatever.
What we can be quite sure of
is that the the central banks
are going to continue
printing more and more fiat.
So the the way that I often sum
that up is, you know, there's
there's no ceiling
on the Bitcoin price,
but that's only because there's
there's no floor on the fiat price
because they're going to continue
diluting it
for years and generations.
It's basically a guarantee that
the central bankers themselves
don't deny.
Critics would say, though,
if you're looking at it as a hedge,
we're in a time of pretty
rapid inflation in the US.
And so why haven't
we seen a huge uptick in adoption?
How would you respond
to those critics?
Well, where are we seeing adoption?
I mean,
I expect
we're seeing more adoption
in the countries
that are seeing hyperinflation.
Yeah.
You know,
America, of course,
has seen an uptick in inflation,
but it hasn't been anywhere near
what some countries
like Venezuela, for example,
have seen.
So, you know, there's it's a
it's a multivariate problem
and it's difficult
even for me to opine upon
why certain people
may adopt or not adopt Bitcoin.
We are in a pretty privileged
financial position.
You know,
basically if you have
a credit card,
if you have a bank account,
you probably don't have
a lot of incentives
to look into hedges
against hyperinflation.
You know, even though,
you know, the
the dollar is going to continue
to inflate,
I think the hyperinflation
risk of the dollar
is still pretty low,
at least relative
to a lot of other countries.
One thing we've noticed
so far walking around
this conference has been
everything from Free Ross to,
you know, screw Dr.
Fauci and RFK Junior type things.
There's a cultural component
that we're noticing here
that seems pretty different
than the Cypherpunk movement.
Your company has come under fire.
You guys are in some ways,
Ethereum proponents.
What do you think of this
sort of cultural strain
that's present within some of this
Bitcoin community?
Yeah, you know, over the years,
while I'm
very interested in the technology,
I would say
one of the more surprising things
has been the
sociological phenomenon
and the interesting
cultural divisions
and strife that have happened,
you know,
for a variety of different reasons.
But so, you know,
Bitcoin started off
and it really was
the earliest adopters of Bitcoin,
I would say
were hardcore
libertarians, anarcho capitalists.
You know,
they saw this as as freedom money,
and it really was
us against the world.
As you know,
we're developing
a parallel economy, if you will,
and it ties in
with Cypherpunk movement
from the sense that,
you know, cipher punks write code,
they don't ask permission,
they just build
and they put it out there
for the market to accept,
digest, reject, what have you.
Now,
over the years,
you know,
Bitcoin has been
attacked by a number
of different people and entities
in a number of different ways,
especially as it has gone
more mainstream
and there have been boom
and bust cycles
and a lot of people have been hurt
in various collapses.
And we've seen various calls,
you know, anti Bitcoin, anti
the entire crypto space.
This is, you know, it
solidified
even more of the sort of us
against the rest of the world
to some of these people.
And as the space has become larger
and more diverse,
we're actually seeing
a fracturing
even within the bitcoin,
quote unquote community.
You know,
some people will get triggered
if you even call it a community,
because,
you know,
there is a saying
which is Bitcoin is for enemies.
This is
really supposed to be
a neutral technology and platform
where anyone who follows
the rules can use it
regardless of
if anyone else disagrees
with who they are
and what they're doing.
So, you know, there are certain
I would say, sub communities
or subgroups of people
that have coalesced over the years,
some of them are more vitriolic
than others.
And, you know,
they coalesce
because they have certain
shared principles,
shared views of what is acceptable
and what is unacceptable.
And so that's some of the stuff
that we have to deal with,
especially on social media.
There is-
it actually comes down
to some phenomenon.
There's a great article out there,
I think it's called., it's
like about knights and mooks.
And basically
it's similar
to sort of political theater
and phenomenon where,
you know,
you build up your narratives,
you build your audience
and you're following
in your community.
And one of the ways that you create
a more cohesive
audience is by having enemies
that you attack
in certain ideological ways.
And so that basically
that same thing
is unfolded within Bitcoin.
And and one of the results
now is that,
you know, the quote
unquote, Bitcoin maximalist
is actually
a very large, diverse tent.
And there are
there are different subgroups
within that tent
that have, you know,
different shared beliefs.
Is the culture around it
a good or a bad thing?
Your you're saying there's
a lot of sort of circling
the wagons.
Does that lead to more people
ultimately being interested?
Is that a spectacle that
people are drawn to?
Or is there some amount of
you know,
it's sort of straying
from what people
were initially attracted to?
Yeah.
I mean, it's it's some of both.
You know,
there are certainly
a lot of people
who get turned off by
some of the vitriol
from some of the groups,
whereas other people get interested
and sucked into it.
But if anything,
I think it may be overblown.
I think the real high level
view of it
is that even with all of the drama
and strife and stuff
that happens on various platforms
in and around Bitcoin,
the vast majority of people
who use Bitcoin
don't know about any of that.
You know,
they're not tuned
into those social networks
or at least those particular areas
and communities
where the drama
and strife is happening.
They just see Bitcoin
as a thing that they're using.
You were talking a little bit
about how you really like the
the bear market.
The fact that
there's a little bit less hype
or the hype has been deflated
surrounding crypto and Bitcoin,
and we're seeing that a little bit
at this conference.
It's much more sparsely
attended compared to past years.
You were saying that you think
this is actually
a really good thing.
Could you talk a little bit
more about that? Absolutely.
I'm not a fan of the
the mania bull
run phases
because of the type of people
that it attracts when the really-
we might call them
the tourists or the larpers
or in many cases, the scammers,
the con men show up.
It's because they see, you
know, fast, easy money
and they're here to get rich quick.
And, you know, I'm
in this for the long term.
I look at Bitcoin
as our best opportunity
to create
a multigenerational project.
You know,
I think
the average lifespan of a fiat
currency is measured in decades.
Bitcoin,
I think we're coming up on
14 years.
So Bitcoin is actually
getting close
to exceeding
the lifespan of the average
fiat currency.
And because it's an open
source project,
I believe it is
very well positioned
to last for decades,
if not centuries,
as long as we take care of it
and maintain it.
But getting back to the,
you know,
building during bear
markets, it's just
it's a lot more peaceful
and easy to do
because you have
fewer distractions.
You know, as developers,
we're able to put our heads down
and, you know, focus
on creating new functionality,
delivering
based on the demands of our clients
and our users.
And that's
what we've seen happening
really even just this year,
like the past five or six
months, it's been great
from a developer standpoint.
You know,
even though
I'm neutral on stuff
like ordinals and tokens,
it's just interesting to see
that innovation happening.
And yes, it
you know, it creates some conflict,
but I like to see
conflict and friction
because that's how we come up with
with new challenges,
which we then find
new solutions to.
Jameson Lopp,
thank you for sitting down
with Reason. Great to be here.